you're not just such a shame was he 38  so he's so young man it's just such a  [ __ ] chain just a great guy too yeah  he was on food truck and he came into  drudge Training Center when he was first  popping on the scene at 170 and my God  the talent that dude possessed was  nutsos Southpaw traditional you're just  a university anything like it and that  and I remember looking it was like 220  some pounds like you fly out 170. this  is nuts dude remember he fought in uh  what was that World Series knocked out  or he went to I think decision or lavski  like the guy is a Savage man his fights  with DC  it's just such a shame man it's such a  freaking shame yeah super such a bummer